- [Nathan] Having a professional
maid come to your home
is one of life's great luxuries.
But what begins as a desire
to have a tidy house,
often turns into a day
long dance where your home
isn't fully yours.
- Ah, is okay if I go?
- Oh, you wanna clean here?
- Cleaning around here?
- Oh, yeah, sure.
A house clean is a full day inconvenience.
And that gave me an idea that would help
Candy Pularez of The Help maid service
in Glendale California offer her customers
a speedier clean.
Nathan.
- How are you doing?
- I always do a weak handshake up front
to establish that I'm not a threat.
- Okay (laughs awkwardly)
Okay, that's nice, cool.
- [Nathan] And after some small talk,
we got down to business.
- A lot of people just want
two people there for two hours
and they usually can do a
general cleaning of things.
- So, one maid takes four hours,
two maids takes two hours?
- Mm hmm.
- By that logic, 40 maids could clean
a house in six minutes.
- Yes.
- [Nathan] By offering to clean houses
40 maids at a time,
Candy would not only
double the amount of jobs
she could do in a day,
but her customers would
likely pay a premium fee
for a service that allows
them to have a spotless
home in the time it takes to go out
and grab a cup of coffee.
The Plan, for The Help to
offer the fastest clean
in the country with 40 maids.
- Well if a customer asked for that,
if they want 20 people, 40 people,
in their house, I could provide
it 'cause I have the teams,
but they've never really
asked for a turbo clean
or anything like that.
- No one knows to ask for something
that hasn't been invented yet.
- It just, I don't know how it would work.
- Candy was intrigued, but
knowing that coordination
would be our biggest challenge,
I first needed to do a test.
So, I found a guy who was
willing to try out the service.
Do you know the measurements of this room?
And mapped out a detailed floor plan
of the inside of his house.
Oh, is there something?
- Yeah, I think somebody
stepped in dog shit outside
and brought it in here, so.
- Oh, I hope that wasn't me.
So, I guess they'll get that too then.
- That'd be great.
- With a house to clean,
the next day I had Candy
assemble four of her best maids
back at the office to be team leaders.
Seven in the kitchen,
five in the living room.
And together we came up with a
sure fire plan to execute
a six minute clean.
For this to work the maids would have
to travel together.
So, I had a bus rented and
outfitted with branding
and I parked it at a central location
where all the maids could meet.
Candy was able to assemble the 40
we needed from her roster
and after dividing them into groups,
the team leaders assigned each individual
maid a specific task.
And after all the maids
loaded on to the bus,
Candy had to head back to the office,
so it was all up to me to make this work.
- Let's do this.
- Okay!
- Okay, come on!
- Knowing that this would
have to be executed like clockwork,
while on route to the house I made sure
that each maid had her
individual role down pat.
What's your job?
- I'm doing the mopping
under the bed, the um, bed.
- You seem a bit unsure, so I just,
you can't be second
guessing when we're in there
it's gonna go really fast.
What's you're job?
The sink?
Is that gonna take six minutes, the sink?
- Mhm, yeah.
- It will, it'll take six minutes?
Okay.
- Moments later we arrived
at the client's home.
There was nothing more I
could do to prepare them now.
Alright, we're gonna do this.
- Okay, now?
- Yes.
- The future of my concept
was in the hands of a bus full of maids.
Alright, ready?
Go!
(chattering in Spanish)
Faster, go, go, go, go, go!
(upbeat music)
Pick up the pace!
Hurry in.
(upbeat music)
It's cool, huh?
- Oh, yeah, this is amazing.
(upbeat music)
- Are you in a relationship right now?
- L.A. is a really tough town to meet
good people, so I guess it makes me
in between relationships.
(upbeat music)
- How was your last relationship?
- Um, you know, we were pretty serious
and played house for a while
yada, yada, yada, she
married her ex-boyfriend
and I'm in LA training dogs.
- Oh, crap.
(upbeat music)
Hurry, hurry, hurry, as fast as you can!
Let's go guys, come on.
Great job, come on guys.
Come on guys.
Once all 40 maids were out,
I brought Jim in to see if he
was satisfied with his clean.
- It hasn't looked this
good since we moved in,
realistically, it hasn't
looked this good since
we moved in.
This place was dirty
too, I mean, you know.
- Yeah, it looked terrible.
Alright guys, we didn't hit
our six minutes exactly,
we were eight minutes and 16 seconds.
Regardless, Jim was very
happy with his clean.
- Amazing job, y'all did a wonderful job,
thank you very much.
Absolutely.
- What do you think of Jim?
He's such a great guy
for hosting you, huh?
(laughter)
And he's single, ladies, I don't know.
You interested in any of them, or?
- You're very kind but
they did all the hard work
they deserve the applause,
they really did a good job.
- He could do some hard work on you.
(clears throat)
(sighs)
Alright.
(upbeat music)